So, we saw that six frames per second was usable, but not very fast. In fact for
video games, the minimum rate is often, 30 frames per second or even 60 frames
per second. These numbers are not arbitrary, but are tied to the hardware
itself. Most monitors these days, at least in America, refresh at 60 Hertz,
which means display the image 60 times a second. This is called the refresh
rate. This value is part of the monitor itself, not something that varies. This
value of 60 Hertz gives an upper limit on the frame rate, the number of new
images per second. However an application can certainly have fewer frames per
second. So, for example, say it takes us a tenth of a second to compute and
display each new image. This would mean our frame rate is 10 frames per second.
The display itself may refresh, that is, send it's stored image to the screen 60
times a second. But most of those images will be the same. In fact, each
computed image will be refreshed 6 times on the screen. In the film industry,
the frame rate is 24 frames per second. However, the refresh rate can be 48 or
72 hertz with each frame, repeatedly projected two or three times. It surprises
people that the frame rate of film is so low compared to computer games with
rates like 60 frames per second. I won't go into the details in this course, but
the key reason that film can have such a comparatively low rate, is that film
captures what is called motion blur. When a frame is captured by the camera,
objects moving will be slightly blurred. This gives a smoother experience and so
a lower frame rate is possible. A fair bit of research has been done in the
field of computer graphics to rapidly create frames with motion blur, since they
look more realistic. See the additional course materials for more on this topic.
However, a film is not interactive. A faster frame rate in an application also
allows a faster reaction time, giving a more immersive feel.